skating's like breathing I can't imagine  not doing it and if I stopped I feel  like drowning that metaphor got dark  real fast  you're a beautiful skater but I'm done  that was my last skate you just a little  scared not a little scared I'm terrified  you're perfect and now when I look at  you all I see as a wasted potential  I could whack her knee with a bat or is  that too 90s I've seen some mural of  competition tapes you were fearless  you've been watching tapes of me it's my  porn my mom didn't think I could do this  I need to show her I can it's about for  a man sits about tragedy it's about sex  that's me  okay I'm used to skating alone you need  time to adjust  I'm gonna ruin everything if you have a  drop cat or hurt her you're gonna wish  you didn't shoot her to do all the way  to the Olympics no pressure  you'll never be a champion never  is everything okay just feels like  everything's falling apart  everyone can have a new chapter  [Music]  you